so today we're gonna
try a new game knight runner uh it's
been explained to me as a mix between uh
super mario and and chess it's like a
platform game sort of where you jump
around as a knight
and you try and um
reach the next level and you have to
watch out for pesky rooks and
and and others so i'm uh
very very new to this game myself but
i'll try to to give it a test run to to
see what's going on
okay right now
it's fairly
standard just jumping around taj mahal
so this is a new
platform pawn
yes so you learn about how the pawn
moves
good to know
and you can pick up coins for
extra lives and extra points
you can probably pick up more stuff than
i'm
managing to okay
and there's the key
should probably grab the other pawn
first but
never mind and then i jump into
portrayal so yeah that was an easy one
so let's see if this one's gonna be a
little bit more difficult
oh so now again yeah here here you see
the danger of the rook
so i'll grab another one
and here if i go there the rook can take
me so i have to escape it
grab the rook
and then get forward ah how do i get to
this one oh there we go
i got another key
and we completed another one
this is going swimmingly so far
only two out of three stars
that's a [ __ ]
oh what's going on here
where am i oh here i am
here's the knights
so how can i
chase elmer
so here we have the bishop
learning how the bishop moves
and try and escape them
okay so i need the heart to
get extra lives
let's grab another bishop
and the pawn and the key
and another portal
you're the best
probably not at this game but in general
i just i don't disagree
[Music]
so
a wild light appears
once again
okay
so that's a bonus
yeah so again this is fairly new to me
why can't i jump there okay
oh
can i grab all of them yes i think i did
oh
no it's caught up with me unfortunately
yeah i'm learning as i go along
how do i get to this one
do i know how the night moves apparently
enough
oh
is the tempo increasing now
i'm grabbing kings like there's no
tomorrow
another one
[Music]
oh
i was captured yeah there you see the i
was
jumping on the night squares i wanted to
take the night but then the knight came
and captured me
so
challenge failed game over so now we
have iceland 1972
and i'm told this is gonna be
a lot more difficult
felt like the first one was even
difficult for me but uh
can i go
can i go grab this
blue lagoon
did i just jump into the blue lagoon
i don't get this
oh
uh
yeah
[Music]
let's run
i was captured
stupid knights again i don't know how
they move
okay let's try again
oh i can jump only here
ugh
how do i get up
lost again
i did even worse than the first time
[Music]
how do i get over there
i i managed it the first time but this
the last two times okay let's try and
let's try and think how does the knight
actually
move
i can't get over there
okay let's
let's go oh
hmm both of these squares tonight takes
me so i have to go somewhere else okay
this is a lot more difficult
it's a lot lot harder
um uh there's a blue thing they teleport
to you so you have to reach that one oh
that's the thing
and now i can go capture stuff so i
should not take that because i would be
can the pawn capture backwards
kind of uh
what kind of a rule is that
maybe this was forward for the pawn
no again i fell for the same trick the
pawn capturing backwards somehow it's
very and counter-intuitive to me
but actually it's not capturing
backwards because if that's a black pawn
it's coming from that side
never mind
[Music]
oh and there
to take that rook and then
just kidding
so frustrating
[Music]
yeah i knew i couldn't do that i just
didn't have time to do anything else
just too dumb to figure this out
where's where's the trick i have to go
and take
that pawn as well
okay you go figure it out i can't do
this
but anyway um yeah here you can see how
it became becomes more and more
challenging um and
your knowledge of how the night moves
moves has to be better and better
out now on the app store